ja wir morgen meine damen und herren
herzlich willkommen im neuen jahr auch
ich wünsche ihnen ein gutes neues jahr
und am ende dieses jahres werden wir
diese pandemie kontrolliert haben meine
damen und herren aber zurzeit müssen wir
die aktuellen maßnahmen zur kontakt
reduktion mit aller konsequenz nutzen um
die infektionszahlen herunterzudrücken
wir alle wünschen uns eine normalität
wir wünschen uns unseren alltag zurück
und zwar mit so wenig einschränkungen
wie möglich aber um das zu erreichen
müssen wir die fallzahlen massiv
reduzieren und sie müssen auch auf einem
niedrigen niveau bleiben es gibt keinen
anderen weg
jede infektion meine damen und herren
jede einzelne infektion ist eine zu viel
und deshalb bitte ich sie erneut
eindringlich schützen sie sich und
schützen sie auch andere vor diesem saß
kopf 2 denken sie an das
gesundheitswesen vielerorts arbeitet das
intensive medizinische personal seit
wochen in schichten die fast keinen
schlaf erlauben und das
durchschnittsalter der patienten auch
intensiv liegt teilweise unter 60 jahren
wegen der hohen infektionszahlen sind
eben auch immer mehr jüngere betroffen
die intensivmedizinische versorgung in
deutschland war wahrscheinlich noch nie
so ausgelastet wie heute die
bestmögliche versorgung schwer
erkrankter menschen kann so nicht mehr
flächendeckend gewährleistet werden
bitte bleiben sie zu hause wenn immer
möglich arbeiten sie von zu hause von
immer das möglich ist
man kann nicht jede aufgabe zu hause
erledigen das ist klar aber ich sehe
unter den arbeitgebern viele
verantwortungsvolle vorreiter ganze
institutionen haben ihre türen
verriegelt und ihren mitarbeitern
heimarbeit ermöglicht daneben gibt es
betriebe deren mitarbeiter noch ins büro
fahren oder sogar persönliche treffen
mit mehreren personen ab halten obwohl
sie von zu hause arbeiten könnten
heimarbeit braucht digitalisierung und
vertrauen
beides bleibt auch nach der pandemie
zentral
jetzt schützt die heimarbeit die
gesundheit von uns allen
dazu brauchen wir noch mehr
verantwortungsvoller
mit geber und wieder an alle gerichtet
bitte halten sie sich immer und überall
an die asl regeln auch wenn sie die
anderen gut kennen
denken sie daran man kann schon
ansteckend sein bevor man symptome zeigt
bitte schränken sie ihre kontakte
wirklich auf das alle möglichste ein
treffen sie möglichst wenig und wenn
dann nur immer dieselben menschen und
wenn sie sich treffen dann bitte
möglichst draußen hier ist die
ansteckungsgefahr nämlich geringer
sie ist aber auch nicht gleich null
achten sie auch draußen bitte auf
abstand und hygieneregeln und wenn sie
draußen gedrängt stehen müssen tragen
sie bitte auch draußen masten und wer
nicht unbedingt muss sollte moment nicht
verreisen
sie haben vielleicht von den neuen virus
varianten gehört stand gestern alle
fälle die uns aktuell bekannt sind
wurden durch reisende nach deutschland
gebracht
und denken sie daran ein negatives
testergebnis gibt keine absolute
sicherheit man kann sich noch in der
inkubationszeit befinden oder man kann
sich erst kurz vor oder nach dem test
infiziert haben so dass der test negativ
ausgefallen ist ein negatives ergebnis
bedeutet nicht dass man völlig unbesorgt
sein kann und dann einfach nicht mehr
die regeln einhalten muss und bitte
bleiben sie bei den ersten anzeichen
einer akuten atemwegsinfektion
mindestens fünf tage zu hause und rufen
sie bei ärzten symptom ihre ärztin an
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren